CAT ALLMAN: Hi, my name's
Cat Allman.
I manage the Google Open
Source outreach team.
My colleague here, Carol Smith,
manages our Google
Summer of Code program.
Hi, Carol.
CAROL SMITH: Hi.
CAT ALLMAN: So please tell
everybody, what is Google
Summer of Code anyway?
CAROL SMITH: So Google Summer
of Code is an online global
university outreach program,
and it's intended to get
students involved in working
on open source software.
And it was born out of the idea
that we wanted students
to be working during their
summer breaks from university
to get involved in open source
software development and work
on things related to what they
were learning in the
university.
And since 2005, it's been
partnering mentoring
organizations, open source
organizations from outside of
Google, with students to work
on a project over the summer
time and are mentored by mentors
within their open
source organization.
CAT ALLMAN: It's
the 10th year.
Are we doing anything special
to celebrate?
CAROL SMITH: In fact we are.
We're doing 10 things to
celebrate since it's the 10th
anniversary.
But we're doing a few things
that I'm really excited to
talk about it and I
want to highlight.
And one of them is that we're
raising the student stipend by
10% this year to $5,500 US
dollars, which is really
exciting for the students
who successfully
complete the program.
And another thing that we're
doing is we're going to be
accepting 10% more students
than we ever have before.
And also, we're going to be
accepting 10 more mentoring
organizations than we
ever have before.
So it's going to be our biggest
year yet in terms of
more orgs, more students,
and more money.
CAT ALLMAN: Fantastic.
What all are we doing
as part of these 10
things, besides that?
CAROL SMITH: Well, we're also
going to be doing a lot of
outreach and trips and travel
to promote the program.
So we're going to-- our team
members are going to be
visiting different countries
throughout the year.
And starting now and running
until the end of the year,
we're going to be visiting the
United Kingdom and Canada and
Poland, Romania and India.
CAT ALLMAN: Wow.
CAROL SMITH: Which
is very exciting.
CAT ALLMAN: Busy people.
So where can students
go online to learn
more about the program?
CAROL SMITH: Well, they can
go to a few places.
They can go to your blog
and that is at
google-opensource.blogspot.com.
They can also subscribe to our
discussion list which is a
Google Groups mailing list, and
they can also visit the
website where we administer the
program from and that's
google-melange.com.
CAT ALLMAN: Fantastic.
What kinds of information
can they find there?
CAROL SMITH: So on
google-melange.com they can
find our frequently asked
questions, which will give
them more information about the
program and how it runs
and answer a lot of questions
that they might have.
They can also see student
projects that have happened in
the past in previous years,
and they can also see
mentoring organizations
that have
participated in the past before.
And most importantly, they can
see our timeline where they
can learn where the
big milestones
for the program are.
CAT ALLMAN: Great.
So when do applications
actually open?
CAROL SMITH: So applications
for the mentoring
organizations that are
interested in participating
next year open on February
3, 2014.
And the deadline for that
is February 14, 2014.
And applications for our
students open on March 10,
2014, and they end on
March 21, 2014.
But I want to say that I think
if students are interested in
participating, they really
should just take the time to
reach out to an open source
organization that they're
interested in working
with now, and
they can make contact.
The great thing about open
source is that you can
participate any time you want
outside of GSOC as well.
CAT ALLMAN: Fantastic.
Are we doing anything else?
CAROL SMITH: In fact we are.
We're also going to be doing a
big event next year that's
going to be celebrating the
10th anniversary, and you
should stay tuned to our blog
if you're interested in
learning more about that,
because we're going to be
announcing things
about that soon.
CAT ALLMAN: Wow.
So we're going to be really
busy, and we hope that you
will join us.
Please do come and check
out the site.
That's google-melange.com to
learn more about the program.
And if you like what you see,
if you think it would be of
interest to your friends, your
fellow students, family
members, please do let
them know about it.
We want to get even more
students involved in free and
open source software.
And we hope that includes you.
Thanks for watching.